temperature of at least 1 400 degrees is
needed to turn sand into some of the
world's most precious glass carefully
crafted vases and chandeliers made by
hand and by mouth
learned to craft from his father it took
him more than six years to master I like
to say
you'll learn your whole life the glass
has a different temperature every
morning it acts differently the colors
and so on it depends on the day every
piece is original it depends on the
piece of glass you take Bohemian glass
is widely recognized for its high
quality to produce it a constant flow of
high pressure gas is needed if the
temperature dips the whole production
process fails but since the energy
crisis gas bills have soared from an
average of twenty thousand to one
hundred thousand dollars a month we are
just struggling to preserve the craft to
keep it going and I think if this lasts
blow it actually kicks in that would
potentially mean a definite in
disruption and final disruption of the
industrial existence
entirely yeah
it's a skill that takes many years of
practice but these world famous
glassblowers don't know for how much
longer they can continue this shows how
the energy crisis is not only affecting
modern Industries but centuries of drugs
as well while the owner of this 100 year
old factory is fighting for survival
dozens of others here in the north of
the Czech Republic have already been
forced to close down
certainly the world would lose some of
its beauty for sure and yeah it would be
a shame we would hate to to see an end
do something that's been around for 300
years
this Workshop hopes to survive the
coming winter by hiring more workers
instead of laying them off the plan is
to make more products with the same
amount of gas and so make up for the
huge energy bills despite the crisis and
high inflation worldwide there's no sign
of any drop in demand for Bohemian glass
step fast on Al Jazeera in kamenitsky
shanov